[Music]
oh my god
as people gear up to spend this holiday
season with or without their loved ones
we wanted to explore what makes a family
we brought together seven families for
the biggest cast of odd man out
yet and we are a family we are a family
we're your family we are our family we
are our family
and we are are a family
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
remains
they'll win the cash prize this is odd
man out
hi i'm jen i'm alex and i'm ryan and
we're from orange county california
are you guys excited uh yeah yeah we're
gonna win this thing
i'm iris hi i'm iris i'm liberty
and we are family we live in anchorage
alaska
so we're gonna rely heavily on our
intuition
ask a lot of questions hi i'm tamara
i'm paul and we are from london and we
are
from blocks it's honestly my favorite
youtube show so i'm pretty excited to be
part of it
and she dragged me into it the truth
will come out easy
like if they're nervous trying to figure
out something to say my name is emily
my name's chris we're twins we're twins
fraternal rat twins
you hi i'm jacqueline
i'm jada i'm jordan i'm mirage and i'm
huey
we got to analyze every
hi my name is phu hi my name is lynn so
the strategy that we are planning to use
is to look at people's body language and
kind of like looking
for answers that are generic and there's
no uniqueness in them
i think we're gonna catch who the ball
is pretty soon
[Music]
they all look related they all look like
they could be family boy and girl
the blondies definitely their family i
think the group of three in the middle
is the fake family i think so too
something something looks uh
yeah but we look related no true true
but we might
well i hope
i mean if we get kicked out and they're
just like there's no way she can be the
mother because she was so young
then i'm okay with that
i'm going to do in pasta oh my god
really
where should we go yeah yeah okay so
green lemon because i think like if they
put a lot of people it's like it's gonna
be hard for us i'm most suspicious of
the nomads we'll pick the ones with
green
lemon okay green lemonade they're just
two people in there
i think we should vote for the three
people i think so yeah okay
one two three okay no man
no man's okay okay we already have a tie
you guys
we're gonna bring together the three
teams to plead their case
the first team to plead their case is
impastas
hello hi um so we are sister
and go and we're from texas
and we're not you know we're like blood
related for sure
um yeah we just have like different
yeah we have pretty similar
face shape um we're both
round i guess
[Music]
yeah that's it i don't know
the next group to plead their case is
nomads
so we are siblings one two three and
four
and that's my dad and that's my mom i
think what threw people off
is the fact that my oldest son looks a
lot like his mama
yes he went there
and the rest of them took after me
look look at me in his face we look the
same look at that
this is really good mom don't say
yes we're family like mom
last one green lemon
hi so i'm emily i'm chris i don't know
pleading our case we're both from la
jolla california because
we're both born in scripps hospital um
we're both blonde
yeah fraternal twins so we're not
identical he's five minutes older and he
holds it over
my whole life literally the best five
minutes of my life
no um i don't know i don't know how to
prove it really
our mom's name is bridget our dad's name
is rick
um we're both sort of similar but very
different in other ways we currently
live together because we're both going
to college in new york
i go to nyu i got hunter college yeah i
love the way he was like
the best five minutes of my life he
sounds like something that's quite weird
for sure
they were real sisters yeah
[Music]
i think the last ones are just students
who are friends
or the green lemons okay
the team that has eliminated this first
round is
impossible oh
we never have to explain to anyone that
we are family like
we usually it's pretty obvious so it was
kind of
like weird and we definitely did not
prepare for that yeah
for this round we're gonna be playing
the most likely two challenge
i will read out who's most likely to
blank
and as soon as i finish reading that out
you guys need to point to whoever
is most likely to do that thing within
your family who's most likely to fart
loudly in a crowded room
who's most likely to shave their head
okay biggest drama queen
most likely to blow all their money in
las vegas
who's most likely to fall down a flight
of stairs oh that's
you i'm in the elevator
who's most likely to go to jail
because you know we better ask her what
she's been up to
most likely to cry during a sad movie
who's first to die in a zombie
apocalypse
who's most likely to total their car
who's most likely to leave dirty dishes
in the sink
me who's the loudest part
completely who's most likely to throw a
fit in a game of monopoly
i think that's you i think that's last
christmas
christmas is different
but i don't think we should over correct
like you know we just had to be
ourselves
i think it's between the three
musketeers and green lemon
i think green line okay let's go for
green lemon i'm going with green lemon
i would like to go back to greenland
yeah i'll green lemons the twins are too
in sync they're not
they're not yeah and they're cute
[Music]
yeah we're going with the cuties the
nomads feel like a family so yeah
musketeers
let's go cuties yeah because it never
fails
we're voting for green lemon because
things were not specific
the team eliminated this round is
green lemon
i said this quick everyone was like
touching each other
yeah i guess we were kind of waiting i
felt i was like should i get closer to
you
i'm i'm super like it could be
a number of people the cuties could be
the blocks yeah
i don't know
[Music]
what is your weirdest family tradition
every
thanksgiving we watch sweetie
on thanksgiving we king crab we're in
anchorage alaska and we eat king crab
instead of turkey
every christmas we were never really at
home we were just going to friends
houses
dash to one house and then dash to the
knicks
they're divorced so i have like four
families to go to every single year
okay i'm like you know four hours
dad was a foreign exchange student he
came here had a host family
so what his mom and dad host is now our
nana and papa so we spend thanksgiving
with them yeah what do you guys fight
about because we all seem to get along
i know sometimes i just say iris just
likes to argue like she's always
contrary you know like everything i say
she wants to like take issue with so we
fight about
conjuring things we even fight about
that she's like
mom you say that's so absolute and i'm
like oh
i don't always
literally the only thing we ever argue
about is the dishes
and cleaning when i come home from work
and i see the house in the mess i'm not
very happy
i have a big one what they got divorced
now in the middle of it
that was
for the mom who was that's his daughter
thanks for the compliments though that
means i must be younger sorry
[Applause]
who was the earliest for who was the
earliest birth and who was the hardest
oh my gosh actually because she was the
first one
so it was the hardest one and he's my
love so it was basically the easiest way
and with this it was very easy just the
first one was very hard
yeah for me it didn't hurt at
we all speak the different language we
think the same language
yeah more than one language yeah
language yeah our second language yeah
so our parents
our parents their first language is
arabic at the end of that like i know
because if you all speak a different
language are you serious
we're gonna go with the nomads because
we think they like they slip
they slip their nomads are definitely
family do you think so yes
the people i believe like three
musketeers
especially being divorced let's vote for
the blocks okay okay
always feed them why would they fight
only about the dishes you can't fight
about your yeah
so who are we gonna go for the blocks
that's us
the sleeping ladies okay the people from
london
their father and daughter father no i i
trust the people from london
as a family as a family like the biggest
fight wouldn't be over video games yeah
team cutie's final answer
the blocks are like cuddling you know
yeah they're super close right now
suddenly it's like kind of sitting there
okay maybe we used to see ladies because
they could be
they could just be really good neighbors
okay
so the team eliminated this round is
the sleeping ladies
[Music]
what oh that was a curveball why is this
yeah that's a curveball all right we
wrote them next again you got like
really like
[Music]
i still think it's probably the green
lemon i think it's probably imposter
okay
my question is for y'all tell us a story
or an example of a time when you had to
call someone else on behalf of your
family member his host mom
we referred to her as nana she like
passed two years ago but we always used
to call her and like
we always used to like call her to like
bail us out of things and things like
that
a lifesaver for all of us there wasn't a
lot of problems
like a jail like we would be more
comfortable
she like leaves me just like leaves the
house i don't know where she went
so then i call everybody i know that it
could possibly be with her i'm like does
anybody know where she is
if daddy's ever done something that
doesn't i'm not very happy about
i'll call my uncle and report him to my
uncle
and he'd be like but it would always be
a jokey thing but he'd be like the
mediator and just try to help out uh i
had a question for
team cutie so like uh how are you guys
related
and like uh who's the youngest and
oldest okay just and about the youngest
but huey is our godfather and
um i'm the middle child jordan's the
youngest and japanese oldest
and mirage is
no you look young too as a god
thank you i was just asking what's the
relationship between um
your godfather and your mom we're like
best friends
i went through a divorce i went through
breast cancer all that kind of stuff he
helped me
and he helped me like through that time
too but we're also like comedians
and we do a lot of like uh shows
together so i was
i was really involved with them and
their family with the girls and then
mirage was like
you know would you be their godfather so
that's how we became a family
no matt dad who's your favorite child
uh emily i'm really sure i have to think
about that
it was me please go
[Laughter]
the cuties the godfather one yeah yes i
think
this is the first time we've agreed you
know so we're going to go with the
blocks
yeah we're going to go with you
i do feel like people came for us a
little bit as well yeah yeah
i also think they were just interested
in
and the team that is eliminated this
round is
the box
i think we did well we were voted out i
think we lasted
longer than i thought we'd last if
everyone feels confident that they
already
caught the mole give me a thumbs down
and we can
end the game if you'd like to keep
playing the game
give me a thumbs up and the game will
continue we're done
we're done if the screen behind you
turns green
you guys have voted the liars out and
you win
if the screen behind you turns red the
liars are still
in the game and you lose ready
[Applause]
can the moles please reveal themselves
[Music]
now
you guys are flatmates and students yeah
so yeah
i did it and we're almost like the two
like blondes that kind of look alike in
our friend group so we get called like
siblings anyway so we're like
maybe we'll try it yeah it was fun
i kind of feel bad for team cuties
because yeah i feel bad
oh man i want them all to come over for
thanksgiving every family was different
i
love the nomads i want to get to know
them and it's nice to see like
even um the divorced couple come
together with their daughter
families come in all forms and sizes and
colors i think it's up to every family
to define themselves
i was actually pleasantly surprised
because i really thought that these
strangers
might see the idea of our family which
is unconventional and not believe it and
vote us out right
that's what i was worried about yeah so
it was actually really beautiful happy
thanksgiving
oh my gosh if we think about it everyone
is siblings
everyone is related to each other
[Music]
you